here times best-selling author does
brought first garnered attention with
his fictional look at Wall Street trader
in the ghost of Manhattan now he's out
with his third novel it's called trophy
son it chronicles the intense and
isolating life of Anton a young tennis
prodigy
despite the highs that come with every
when Anton struggles with his identity
off the court
doug brunt joins us at the table when I
fed hello Doug hello when I finished it
I thought this could a make a great
movie because it's such a it's such an
interesting dynamic between Anton and
his dad who really is a classic tennis
dad if there is such like a what they
call stage mother he's a stage father
right trophy son is very aptly named
thanks yeah funny enough that the
initial title is specialized which I
loved all the way through and I got to
with my editor nice it's mean eyes eyes
you know about the title yeah okay but
this is a much better title it does
capture that father-son relationship and
that really is such a common dynamic in
professional tennis there is often a
tiger mom or a domineering father behind
the intense upbringing that these
athletes have and parents in general we
were talking about dominating they can
be that's right and it's an interesting
shift in our culture now because the
novel's been compared to the Great
Santini and one of the differences from
the 1970s when pat conroy wrote that
novel is our system is much more like a
giant Great Santini that you enter with
eighth grade or eight-year-old travel
sports teams and if you want to have a
high school athletic experience today
you need to as an eight-year-old lock in
behind a sport and commit and it's a
much more intense way and much more
specialized way to grow up for our kids
what you think and I know you word about
this for time you think that money and
that sort of specialization has actually
ruined sports it's problematic and
fortunately there's a growing tide
against that Steph Curry wrote a great
article whose way of stuff great great
basketball player wrote a great article
so you know whose staff Colonel is done
better in the playoffs this is hard news
over here yeah that's true he's so good
at sports my goodness we're like Jeff
hurry Under Armor shoes thank you very
much it would Harley didn't like I said
Steph Curry's a great basketball by the
warrior
I was talking to a Duke basketball okay
go ahead you go to you wrote a piece a
little while ago talking about the
benefits of playing multiple sports for
as long as you can and that you'll be a
better basketball player if you don't
play only basketball through high school
what I'm McEnroe used to say that back
did played soccer in the foot work
required made even much better to
explain yeah I was it's a Jordan speith
to I mean another great example of kind
of a multi-disciplinarian sport but what
do you think in terms of this book I
mean you could almost you can look at it
in the edge of the way that kids are
being driven into one sport and their
parents are crazy with them on Memorial
Day weekend traveling around the country
in these club sports it it's hard on the
whole family to I think some parents are
into it and some kids are into it and
that's great you see that all the time
but many parents are these reluctant
participants in this system i I don't
want to drive my kids around to nine
different weekend I'd like to go camping
and roast some s'mores and that's a very
healthy activity as well and I think
they're hoping on a raise tennis
champion what's wrong and Islam does mr.
mrs. Doug brunt Megan Kelly want to do
that too she does she's much more about
dancing around the bonfire and roasting
s'mores too so she and I are on the same
page about that let's let help help us
understand what you found out about
performance-enhancing drugs when you
looked at the tennis world without
naming we know it exists in the sport
there have been positive tests and
suspensions and there's been a lot of
reporting from credible credible sources
about the existence of drugs and sport
and the question is how prevalent and
how effective is the testing and it's
interesting to look at the examples of
other sports where this has been an
issue like cycling or baseball and Lance
Armstrong used to say I'm the most
tested athlete on the planet I've been
tested a thousand times but that's
meaningless because he knew how to beat
the test and then you flash forward a
little bit and he says yes I was using
it all these years but it wasn't really
cheating because I was just leveling the
playing that everyone is doing it but in
this particular book you name the names
of real tennis players and you imply
that they've used performance-enhancing
drugs can you do that because I'm
thinking if you had written a story
about TV news and you said Norrell
Donald's and alcoholics say and used her
real name or megyn kelly or Gayle King
or Charlie Rose couldn't you get in
trouble by saying that be
as you are using our real names as you
did in this book well as a legal matter
it's it's fiction and this is a
character speculating dialogue but yeah
there is lots of speculation around
certain players and that's basically
what this character is doing there there
are a number of people many people out
there who believe that a number of
players in this sport are kind of in the
place where Lance Armstrong was and k2 I
love that in a novel lake and yeah and
I'm not going to speak for James on on
any of this stuff a lot of what he and I
talked about and he actually read the
book on his flight to Paris where he has
a budding broadcasting career as well
he's such a great guy and well for the
Tennis Channel he wrote back saying it's
a page-turner of a novel and he wrote
back saying it captures that gut-check
feeling you get both on and off the
court for a professional player yeah a
lot of what we talked about was the
mechanics of the drug testing how the
tournament official meets you courtside
with the clipboard and they take you
back to the bathroom and you they watch
you until they get pee in the cup even
if you shower first we are at a time but
Doug Brunt congratulations on your book
trophy sign is on sale now we'll be
right back